good morning it's seven o'clock this is
sky news breakfast live from western
super mario in south west england as
storm unis hits home we'll bring you the
latest from our correspondents around
the country as residents and emergency
services brace themselves for what could
be the worst storm in 30 years and we
want to hear from you as well let us
know how you're affected it's friday the
18th of february
stay indoors schools are closed trains
cancelled homes without power and the
army placed on standby with a possible
danger to life as storm eunice arrives
i'm here in emily and gloucester where
flood warnings have been issued along
the river seven
here in wales coastal communities are
bracing themselves the full force of
storm units trains cancelled and
hundreds of schools shut
and this is the scene from our live
storm cam in nuke in cornwall the calm
before the storm
also making the news this morning
president biden is set to host a meeting
with world leaders as fears of a new war
in europe intensify
here in moscow vladimir putin will meet
with a firm ally the leader of belarus
as their country's staged joint military
drills along ukraine's border
nhs leaders call for free covet tests
and isolation rules to continue as the
government prepares to end england's
coronavirus restrictions
and of course we'll keep you up to date
with the weather with storm eunice
expected to bring damaging and
disruptive winds to the south today and
heavy snow and blizzards took parts of
the north
[Music]
good morning welcome to sky news
breakfast live from western super mario
as storm eunice is set to batter much of
the uk and ireland today with extremely
strong winds and torrential downpours
the met office has issued a rare red
weather warning and says conditions
could see flying debris resulting in
danger to life and damage to buildings
and homes it really is a day to stay at
home if you can cancel your travel plans
and stay away from coastal areas
and here's why storm units is set to
bring widespread disruption to many
parts of the country with red warnings
for wales the southwest and the
southeast
freshening winds will gust to 70 up to
70 to 80 miles an hour inland and up to
90 miles an hour along coasts with the
risk of storm surges winds of this
strength are rarely seen and pose a risk
to life an amber wind warning is
enforced for much of england and wales
with the potential for damage to
buildings and homes travel disruption
and power outages too
the yellow warning for northern england
northern ireland and scotland is for
wind and snow with blizzard conditions
expected in
places now storm units is already having
an impact around 2000 properties in
devon and cornwall have lost power
already western power disruption
is hoping to have people reconnected
with in the next hour
storm eunice is set to cause major
disruption to travel to all train and
bus services in wales have been
suspended for the whole day
and the m48 bridge over the seven has
already been closed with police
suggesting there's also a high risk for
the closure of the m4 prince of wales
bridge 2.
in england rail providers including
london northeast railway southeastern
avanti west coast and east midlands
railway are encouraging people not to
travel
and while scott rail didn't it doesn't
expect the same level of disruption as
was caused by storm dudley they are also
suspending suspending some services too
now hundreds of schools will be closed
today around the uk that includes all
schools in north wales
all schools and colleges in somerset as
well as dozens of schools in cornwall in
the republic of ireland schools across
nine counties will also be shut after
met erin issued a red wind warning for
court kerry clair and waterford
hundreds of flood warnings and alerts
have been placed around the uk including
in england the environment agency has
issued ten severe flood warnings all
located around the history of the river
seven the highest possible warning with
a risk to life there have also been
117 further flood warnings and alerts
around wales there have been 136
warnings and alerts made as well as 14
currently in place around scotland
in ireland there are red and yellow
warnings for flooding in some
coastal counties
and this is the scene from our live
storm cam at fistral beach in newquay in
cornwall as gale force winds batter the
southwest we'll have this on your screen
throughout the morning as we monitor the
storm
flood warnings have been issued along
the river 7-2
well we can join sky's katie barnfield
now who's live for us in epne on the
seven in gloucestershire good morning to
you katie what's the situation there
good morning well here in apni and
gloucester they're really being told to
expect the worst of storm eunice this
morning that red danger to life warning
for wind is now in place here people are
being told to expect wind speeds of 70
or even 80 or more miles an hour this
morning this is also one of those ten
areas that have been issued with the
severe
flood warning most are concentrated
around here along the river seven the
environment agency is very worried that
the combination of a tidal surge
expected here on the river 7 along with
these extremely high wind speeds could
lead the river to break its banks now
last night people were out trying to
shore up their homes and businesses with
sandbags but the fire brigade was going
door to door telling people really it's
not enough and that they needed uh to
leave their homes they've also been
setting up respite centers around here
for people to go to but many people were
telling me last night that they didn't
want to leave and this morning a lot of
people are still here they were hoping
that it would not be as bad as as feared
but this morning people are being told
to expect the worst
okay katie for now thank you we'll be
back to you as the storm hits we can
join ashland hurry nag too he's in
port call on the south coast of wales
just a stretch of water away from where
we are good morning to you ashna what's
it like there
good morning sally yeah whilst you're
bracing yourself for storm eunice it's
very much hit this part of south wales
all the way from swansea all the way
across to newport the coastline is is
going to be battered over the next few
hours and already the tide has fully
come in you can see the waves
occasionally splattering over the
barriers this is no doubt going to be an
incredibly dangerous piece of coastline
it is because of this weather that all
schools in wales today have been shut
now it's not going to be too disruptive
i have to say to children as they do is
the half term that starts tomorrow
having said that though public transport
2 heavily disrupted the bus company
stage coach cancelling all buses in
south wales if buses are running they're
not going to be double-deckers because
of the risk of course of those high
winds that you can probably feel and see
me getting battered by the other thing
that's been disrupted is all trains
today in wales being cancelled
throughout the entire country i think
that really goes to show how dangerous
things could be and we've already seen
two people out for a run today not
stopping their daily ritual but there
are a load of flats along this coastline
and anyone who has any garden furniture
or any loose bits of furniture have been
encouraged to take those inside some
people heeding that advice but many
people aren't i guess we'll have to wait
and see how this plays out over the next
few hours but certainly already shaping
up to be quite a dangerous place to be
okay ashna take care thank you very much
ashley harinag monitoring the situation
in south wales uh for us and of course
that first red alert to hit the
southwest of england and south wales
only began
around eight minutes ago this is a
developing
story you may well learn of information
and the impact of storm eunice before we
do this is something we would like to
share on air as the storm hits the uk do
send in any photos or videos or
information of the impact of storm
eunice from where you are to news at
sky.com that's news at sky.com we'd love
to hear from you plenty more throughout
the morning but for now it's back to
kamali in the studio
well thank you very much sally and ashna
and katie moore on that story as we
continue throughout the morning well
let's bring in now the uh security
minister damian hines for some more on
this and exactly how the government is
planning to respond to what's happening
good morning to you minister um
how concerned is the government about
the danger to life by this storm
well of course concerning it's unusual
to have a red warning particularly
unusual to have
a second red warning uh yeah we we're
only just out of storm dudley and storm
eunice obviously is something we all
need to be concerned about strongly
encouraging people to take precautions
and make sure make sure we stay safe
i mean that's the advice take
precautions but there's enough
preparation been put in place we have
had this forecast coming for the past
few days
yeah indeed and of course i mean over
the
over the sort of longer term a lot of
learning's been done from storm arwen
particularly on
on dealing with with welfare issues
staying in touch with people staying in
touch with customers for for the
networks but then also in the immediate
term you know there are troops on on
high readiness standby but the
environment agency on the ground the
networks themselves of course uh have to
be very uh
very much uh plugged in active and and
they are
weather is unpredictable and uh it's
really important that that we all
continue as i say obviously to take
those precautions and try and keep
everyone as safe as possible i mean is
government fearful that people could get
cut off by the weather that's on its way
it's uh hitting now and it'll be
continuing for the next few hours
that that's absolutely a risk i mean a
red warning is what it what it says it
is it is a warning of danger uh there is
a risk uh to to life and and limb uh and
indeed when you have these uh when you
have these big weather events of course
there can be those risks of being cut
off um everybody is
as i say on a state of readiness state
of alert
um but
it but it is you know it is the weather
it is nature and and by its nature
although you know we have we have much
better forecasting and much more science
than ever we've had in the past there is
still quite an element of
unpredictability
yeah better forecasting better science
but are these things going to become
more common as we deal with climate
change
well it does appear doesn't it from the
pattern that there has been an increase
in in the frequency of these big weather
events i mean i leave it to the
scientists to talk about the exact
trends and uh you know exactly how much
you can ascribe to climate change but it
certainly does appear that way doesn't
it that we've had this we've had this
increased frequency and and we certainly
know
that climate change on a global level is
associated with more frequent events and
can cause and can indeed cause danger uh
minister where are the army being
deployed right now currently are they
still in barracks or are they sort of a
high reading of standing by to go to
where they needed
they're at readiness and of course you
know our armed forces are very good at
deploying to where they to where they
need to be to move to move quickly when
they need to they have a lot of
engineering uh expertise civil
engineering expertise uh as well so i
think it is it is very important it's
very useful that uh should there be
calls for for military assistance to aid
the civil efforts
um that that is indeed possible
and what will be done to make sure that
anyone whose uh livelihood is damaged by
this they're looked after there are
often cases in major weather events that
people try and claim on their insurance
and somehow they can't claim uh for the
damage that's been caused by no fault of
their own yeah so look obviously we have
to be really vigilant about that i can't
i can't predict right now what
particular
issues might come up but it's certainly
something that my colleagues across
government indeed across parliament are
very very uh a very alive to we'll make
sure and make sure we stay on top of
okay now are we here you can minister we
must be talk must talk of course about
the geopolitical situation on the border
between russia and ukraine
are you with those who've been speaking
to the newspapers in the past uh 12
hours that war is imminent and it's
going to be horrendous
well there's still there's still a way
out uh it's still with russia uh there
is there is a diplomatic route
and we strongly strongly encourage
russia to to take that route um but
there is that build-up of troops on the
border there is no actual uh
evidence of it of it of it coming down
no sign of it
uh dissipating um so so that threat is
there and you use the word imminent it
might be imminent or it might take a
little bit longer um you know we're
dealing with uh we're dealing with a
regime here in in president putin who
will who who may pick his moments but we
have to stand strong we stand
shoulder-to-shoulder uh with uh with our
friends in the ukraine we're very clear
that were there to be a further
incursion and invasion from russia that
would be very bad it would obviously be
very bad for ukraine it'd be bad for
europe and it would also be bad for for
for russia uh because of because of what
will follow we want to be working with
russia one of the great nations of the
of the world on all these big challenges
we face globally
we don't want russia to be outside that
family of nations and with the sanctions
regime and so on that that would be
necessary so strongly encourage
president putin
to step back and choose that diplomatic
route
okay well the diplomacy will continue as
we watch what's happening on that board
but we'll have you minister i must uh
speak to you about the pandemic as well
there is a decision now to live with
covid that decision by government has
been criticized by nhs leaders saying
that it might be a risk it's a gamble uh
are we happy to just live with this
pandemic as we have it now and stop
giving away free natural flow tests
well i mean
of course we are going to have to learn
to deal with to live with is as you say
with with covert as it moves from
pandemic to to endemic and that there
will be an announcement um about about
exactly how we will
uh how we will go about that but you
know there's bit we've put it been
putting in huge investment in this
country i mean particularly in in the
vaccination program that that is our
you know that that is the number one uh
part of our defense uh against uh
against this precisely minister that but
the nhs confederations say that this
government move is too gung ho do you
disagree with what the nhs leaders are
saying well we
i think we wait to see what the what
what the government's an announcement is
in full on on what all we are going to
do
to uh to to to live with this virus as
we must as as commander we live with
other uh other viruses other illnesses i
mean just yesterday of course there was
the further announcements on the
availability of vaccination for
uh for younger children and we're now
you know over 90 of the over of the over
12 uh population having had that
vaccination this country has been
absolutely in the vanguard
of uh of investing in of of innovating
for uh making sure that we can uh cope
with with what has been of course is
terribly destructive
uh a virus uh but we are now coming to
the stage where where yes of course we
we must prepare
to live with it
uh okay then mr well we've got you a
couple more questions please if we can
there's been reporting this morning that
alexander downer former foreign minister
from australia is going to be advising
the government on immigration policy mr
downer as you will know was responsible
for the push back policy in australia
you in support of pushing migrants back
in the channel
so i've met mr i met mr mr downer he's
doing a review into the operation of of
border force which of course is that is
the force which
uh you know it looks after our border
security at you know at the front end uh
what's happening at the
threat of the border in terms of
illegal immigration organized
immigration crime but also good
smuggling uh some sometimes uh goods and
cash leaving the country illegally um
all of these things that threat is
constantly
evolving it's changing and so it's right
that we
it's right that we review it uh exactly
how we go about those things i think
having
having a you know a different
perspective um fresh eyes looking at
that i think is is a sensible thing to
do
okay damien hines security minister uh
thank you for joining us this morning
thank you very much good morning to you
well still to come on the program
hundreds of schools are shutting trains
cancelled in wales we'll be speaking to
the leader of swansea council some
eunice hits i will also speak to a
meteorologist about the likely impact of
the storm as the met office warns of a
danger to life
hello again this is the scene from our
live storm cam at fistral beach in new
key in cornwall as gale force wins bata
the southwest we'll have this on your
screen throughout the morning as we
monitor events to ireland now
we're scotlands and colleges in several
counties are closed following red
weather warnings there too for snow
and more strong winds we can cross to
our island correspondents stephen murphy
in truly in southwestern ireland good
morning to you stephen what's the
situation like there
yeah the winds have really picked up now
in about the uh the last hour so the
center of the storm according to med air
and that's the irish met office is now
passing over this part of the southwest
of ireland cork and kerry as you say
we're here in truly in county care
there's now four
parts of ireland four counties under a
status red wind warning that kicked in
at 3 a.m and will last here until about
8 a.m and then waterford uh will last
until about 11am it's expected to be
extremely damaging we're hearing that
there's already around 3 000 uh
households without any power here and
gusts of up to 95 miles per hour have
now been recorded off the southwest
coast of ireland that's at the fastnet
lighthouse although that is offshore so
it is expected it's being described as a
high impact storm it is expected though
to move fairly quickly to the east uh as
it makes its way uh over the rc and into
the uk so we're hearing that these uh
heavy winds the damaging winds that will
probably bring uh some coastal flooding
as well the worst of that should pass
through this part of ireland by around
midday and we will then wait and see
just how much damage it has caused here
okay stephen thank you very much we'll
be back to you throughout the morning
and storm eunice has already caused
travel disruption
across the country as you would expect
and we can get more on that from sky's
milena visilinovich who's at london's
paddington station for us good morning
to you melena what's the situation like
now and what can we expect later on of
course a red warning due to hit london
at 10 o'clock too
good morning sally already a lot of
cancellations here no trains running to
either cardiff or swansea in wales we've
just seen that there's been
cancellations for bristol trains as well
although i in theory they should be
running once per hour and there's a
speed restriction alongside along the
entire great western network in order to
keep the passengers safe which surely
will disrupt services as well and as you
said there another red warning for east
of england including london from 10 am
today so that is likely to make the
situation even worse now network rail
operators have asked passengers not to
travel today if they can help it and
looking around the station seems like
most people have heeded that warning
it's a work day it's rush hour and major
commuter station in london it seems
pretty pretty empty actually and those
people who have tickets valid for today
can use them up until monday now rail
operators are also warning that these
disruptions are likely to last
throughout the week and as the train
tracks are being examined for damage
okay milena for now thank you and we can
speak now to the environment agency
spokesperson for the midlands that's roy
stokes a very good morning to you uh mr
stokes of course this situation has
developed through the night with a red
warning now in place for london and the
south east as well what more can you
tell us about what to expect in the
coming hours
yeah good morning sally um yeah we've
been watching this for the last couple
of days and
preparing for this so we've been
checking all of our
uh coastal and sea defenses and we've
got our barriers up along the river
seven corridor um and it's a it's a case
now just seeing what uh comes in this
morning um if if the high winds and the
storm alert wasn't enough we've also got
10 severe flood warnings in place that
means there is the risk to life i cannot
stress uh how important it is to take
heed of these notices and to listen to
the emergency services and take their
advice this is a really serious
situation
of course tidal surges are also expected
with these strong winds what can people
expect if they do live
near the coast or near water in these
red zones
well um
worst case scenario i mean it is
people talk about the perfect storm so
the the high spring tides combined with
this with this storm that's moving in
now is just the worst possible thing
really for the estuary so the chance the
worst case scenario is that some of
those for defenses that are protecting
people over the years could be over
topped we've got people out with high
volume pumps all along the seven stream
as i say we've been preparing this for
this for a couple of days now we've been
able to get our flood warnings out to
people in good time those severe
warnings were issued yesterday to give
people plenty of time to prepare what i
would stress as well is that that folks
listen to the advice from the emergency
services this is a really really serious
situation and i know that people
don't always want to leave their homes
but in this case it might be the best
advice so listen to what you're being
told on the ground keep an eye on things
and um and we'll just watch this come
through now and and hopefully
uh it won't be as bad as we're all
expecting but we always prepare for the
worst and hope for the best
of course your teams at the environment
agency are all too familiar with
flooding dealing with floods uh every
year in the uk uh this is one of the
most serious storms to hit the country
in around 30 years
how concerned are you about what we may
see by the end of today
well we're very concerned because it's
it's quite a an unusual event really
like you say we're we're well versed in
just the flood events but with this the
high winds as well we you know nobody
really knows what kind of damage that
that could cause there'll be all sorts
of different complications that we've
maybe not seen for quite some time as
you say is probably the worst one in 30
years and but we're pretty confident
that our infrastructure and our defenses
are in good shape so they'll be doing
what they were designed to do but it's
what effect this wind has on that on
those as well and whether that sort of
extra force from that wind could see
some over topping of some of those
defenses which is why it's really
important that people listen to
what's going on on the ground it's
fantastic to see all the coverage this
morning so keeping people
in the picture as this as this storm
develops
that is certainly our intention this
morning as the storm hits
in terms of the prime minister yesterday
saying that the army
is on standby at what point would you
need the army to be called in to support
you
well that wouldn't necessarily be our
call so the local resilient former
forums they're the people who obviously
we work alongside our professional
partners there'll be google controls set
up all around the country today and it
will be those forums that will be decide
collectively as to whether that
additional help is required that's
always available to us in in any of the
serious floods so um you know it's kind
of
i won't say standard practice because
this is this is far from from standard
but it's one of the tools if you like
that we can call upon and let's hope
that we don't need to do that but it's
really good and reassuring to know that
that is that facility is there should we
need to call upon it
okay mr stokes we wish you and your
teams all the best for the coming hours
thank you very much indeed for joining
us this morning
now it is forecast to be a dangerous few
hours for the south of england ireland
and south wales as well storm eunice has
arrived that first red warning a rare
red warning issued by the met office
began around half an hour ago here in
the southwest of england and south wales
with winds up to 100 miles an hour
expected in spots certainly it is very
blustery here in western super mario
already a very very choppy uh coastline
with waves already uh breaching
the walls here along the front we will
be monitoring this situation for you
with correspondence around the country
throughout the morning the red warning
here in place until midday another red
warning which has been issued overnight
from the met office begins at 10 o'clock
in london and the south east of england
and that will
continue into the afternoon it's an
uncertain situation the storm will pass
by this evening what we don't yet know
is what damage it will leave behind for
much of the country the advice is to
stay at home there is a danger to life
and we will bring you all the latest as
we get it for now though back to kamali
in the studio
sally thank you very much for now back
to you later now in other news this
morning and the u.s president joe biden
has warned that a russian invasion could
begin within days meanwhile pro-russia
rebels in ukraine have accused
government forces of shelling a village
and russian media has reported that more
troops are returning to their bases well
let's go to moscow for the very latest
on this by bringing in uh dinah magnay
who's standing by frieza good morning to
diana so we've had that word from biden
we've seen that there have been
cease-fire violations this morning just
where are we with the situation on the
ukrainian border right now
i think that there will be an uptick in
ceasefire violations um going forward
the separatists say that they have
experienced increased shelling from the
ukrainian side um i think what we will
see
and what russia will support also is the
separatists playing up the extent of the
ceasefire violations and the ukrainians
playing them down obviously yesterday we
had this strike from the separatists on
a kindergarten and ukrainian territory
uh luckily no one was killed there you
talked about these troops returning to
their bases joe biden said yesterday you
know we're seeing more troops going in
than out i think that what russia is
saying is that some exercises are
finished and some troops are returning
to their bases but it doesn't mean that
others aren't
flooding in to exercises elsewhere and
we have these joint military drills with
belarus still ongoing until sunday
and those are really huge exercises
along uh belarus's southern border with
ukraine and those are the ones of real
concern the leader of belarus alexander
lukashenko is due to meet with vladimir
putin today he's been giving um
some comments while he was watching
those exercises a couple of days ago he
said some rather alarming things he says
that vladimir putin and him will
decide when to bring the troops home but
he also talked about the possible
deployment of nuclear weapons even super
nuclear weapons he said in belarus
at some point in the future now that is
not his power to give but i do wonder
whether
russia has promised a military technical
response if its security guarantees
aren't met is that perhaps something
that might be
uh on the cards for vladimir putin i
don't know it's speculation but it's
concerning from the leader of belarus
concerning indeed okay diana in moscow
for now thank you
also making news this morning and
passengers and crew aboard a ferry
sailing from greece to italy have been
evacuated after a fire broke out on
board 288 people were said to be on the
ferry there are no immediate reports of
any injuries the euro ferry olympia was
headed to the port of blindisi when the
fire starts the cause isn't yet known
at least 117 people have died and over
100 more remain missing after mudslides
in the brazilian city of petropolis on
wednesday the region's governor
described the scene as almost like war
as the first funerals have now been held
hundreds of people are homeless and many
are still feared trapped beneath the mud
government plans to scrap free covid's
tests and self-isolation rules should
not go ahead that's according to a
survey of nhs leaders four in five of
those polls disagreed with scrapping
free lateral flow tests the proposals
are understood to be part of the prime
minister's so-called living with
coronavirus plan that's set to be fully
unveiled on monday
well it's time now for a look at the
weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
as we've been reporting storm units will
bring damaging and disruptive winds to
the south today in heavy snow and
blizzards to parts of the north the med
office has issued several warnings with
the most severe red wind warning now in
force across the south west and
southeast similar warnings are in place
for ireland now it's a windy start for
many with damaging gusts of up to 90
miles an hour for south wales southwest
england and southwest island overnight
rain is clearing east anglia and the
southeast to leave sunshine and showers
but snow and blizzards will persist in
the north the stormy conditions will
intensify through the morning with gusts
widely reaching 60 to 70 miles an hour
locally they could be higher damage and
disruption are likely with coastal
flooding a major concern ireland will
see the wind easing later there'll be a
mix of sunshine and showers some wintry
but more prolonged snow will linger in
the north it will feel cold now the
afternoon will see the strongest winds
transferring eastwards before easing
from the west
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
stay indoors schools are closed trains
cancelled homes without power and the
army placed on standby with a possible
danger to life as storm eunice hits the
uk
[Music]
and this is the scene from our live
storm cam at fistral beach in yuki in
cornwall as gale force wins batter the
southwest
storm munis is set to bring widespread
disruption to many parts of the country
with red warnings for wales the
southwest and the southeast freshening
winds will gust up to 70 or 80 miles an
hour inland and up to 90 miles an hour
along coasts with the risk of storm
surges winds of this strength are rarely
seen and pose a risk to life
an amber wind warning is in force for
much of england and wales with the
potential for damage to buildings and
homes travel disruption and power
outages
the yellow warning for northern england
northern ireland and scotland is for
wind and snow with blizzard conditions
expected in places
well earlier we heard from the security
minister damian heinz about preparations
the government has made
ahead of storm units
there are troops on
on high readiness standby but the
environment agency on the ground the
networks themselves of course
have to be very
very much uh plugged in active and and
they are a red warning is what it what
it says it is it is a warning of danger
uh there is a risk uh to to life and and
limb uh and indeed when you have these
uh when you have these big weather
events of course uh there can be those
risks of being cut off um everybody is
as i say on a state of readiness state
of alerts
um but
it but it is you know it is the weather
it is nature
well we can bring in our political
correspondent tamara cohen now good
morning to you tomorrow of course there
was that emergency cobra meeting
yesterday just how much more prepared is
the government this time compared to the
response we saw after storm irwin with
people in the northeast and scotland
feeling pretty much forgotten without
power for up to 10 days or so
morning sally yes i think the response
to storm irwin as you say um has very
much informed how the government are
dealing with this one we had a cobra
meeting yesterday and i'm waiting for
confirmation that there will be a second
one but i expect there will be a second
one today the energy minister greg hans
was tweeting yesterday saying that
people should stay in touch with their
power networks that people who were
affected by the storms only a few days
ago in yorkshire are now almost all
reconnected and that people should in in
london and in the south western wales
where those red warnings have been
issued for the most dangerous storms
possibly as forecasters are saying the
worst storms for 30 years those people
should be in touch with their power
companies if their supply is affected
and we're stressing that the army aren't
ready to help out if people do get
disconnected and if people are unable to
contact friends and family or get into
emergency situations so the government
trying to put out reassuring messages
very much informed by the response to
that uh storm arwyn and i expect we'll
be hearing more from ministers today as
they try to make sure that if people are
badly affected especially if they lose
their power that the power companies are
ready to step up quickly
okay tamara for now thank you
well wales has suspended all rail
services today and hundreds of schools
across parts of the country have closed
as a result of this impact
of storm units and joining me now is the
leader of city and county of swansea
council rob stewart a very good morning
to you mr stewart what are you expecting
today
good morning sally um well we're braced
for the for the worst of the storm it's
been pretty quiet up until now uh but
the winds have started building in the
last hour or so and uh you know our
teams were out yesterday uh inspecting
uh culverts looking at areas where we
have potential for flooding and then uh
preparing our coastal defenses to make
sure that we're as ready as we can be
for the storm that's due to hit in the
next few hours i mean it is
unfortunately a combination
uh that we
are dealing with of heavy rain over the
last few days which has swelled the
rivers we've got high tides at the
moment and of course this um very very
rare uh red rated storm so uh we're as
repaired as we can be but it is looking
very dangerous for the next few hours
yes the met office doesn't issue these
red warnings uh lightly as you say and
that first red warning began in south
wales around 40 minutes ago along with
the south west
of england what measures have you put in
place for people there who may be
affected
so uh we we we discussed with other
leaders across wales and welsh
government yesterday and we took the
decision to close our school so around
36 000 children in swansea will be
remote learning today um we uh do that
and we did that regularly during
lockdown so
our schools and teachers are ready to do
that we've closed all of our
front-facing services
so all of our library civic buildings
community centers are closed um and our
teams then are stood up so we've got our
highways our tree teams and our other
emergency teams are stood ready to deal
with any of the impacts of the storm
that we we expect to see in the next few
hours so
again we're prepared we've we've given
safety messages and again you know i'd
repeat those if if uh people are uh
choosing to venture out today stay away
from our coastal lines stay away from
our rivers do not put yourself in danger
stay at home if you can
and work from home if you can so you
know this is a really dangerous
situation
uh as you say uh pupils and teachers are
all too well versed these days with
remote learning which i suppose is one
positive uh for them today but in terms
of the impact of potential flooding that
is expected to hit south wales uh who do
you have on standby and at what point
would you want to see the military
called in to assist
so at the present time we have what we
call local resilience teams
and they were coordinating yesterday so
they've been out during the latter part
of yesterday and overnight shoring up
the flood defenses inspecting areas
where previous flooding has occurred so
that we can get ahead of the game if you
like so that we try and prepare as best
we can for likely flooding
at the present time as i said it's been
relatively quiet up to this point but
it's expected to worsen significantly
and very quickly
in the next few hours
and obviously our teams are ready to
respond so at the present time we don't
intend uh given what we've currently
seen to call anybody in but we'll have
to see what the storm brings and as i
said it's not just the the once in
30-year winds and storm severe storm
it's the high tides and the swollen
rivers all coming together that could
present a real challenge for us
okay mr stuart leader of swansea city
council thank you very much indeed uh
for joining us this morning
and of course we would love to hear from
you if you've got any pictures or video
or any information about how storm units
is impacting where you love you live
please do share them with us at news at
sky.com that's news at sky.com that
first very rare red warning to hit the
country began around 45 minutes ago this
is a situation that will develop while
we are on air it could be that you hear
about the impact before we do so do get
in touch and do let us know
for now though back to kamali in the
studio
sally thank you very much for now
now the munich security conference is
being held currently and president biden
is to convene a meeting of world leaders
as kamala harris is at that conference
as the fears grow of a new war in europe
let's bring in now the former uk
ambassador to russia sir roderick lyon
who's joining us
live uh sir roderick thank you very much
for being with us this morning on sky
news so the latest reporting says that
there have been ceasefire violations the
um country is on the brink of being
invaded by russia ukraine is meant to be
it used to live the of the mind that
russia would be crazy to invade ukraine
uh yes we're waiting to hear whether the
russians will reply to the latest
american offer of talks next week but
the problem we have here is that they
might be crazy uh if putin was acting
rationally he certainly wouldn't take
the huge risk of an invasion he would
take the best offer he can get through
negotiations but putin is a man who
mixes the rational and the irrational
he's very often driven by emotion and
vengeance we saw that in chechnya we've
seen that with novichow attacks in
salisbury we've seen that in other
places and at the moment i think he's
driven by an irrational belief that the
west is trying to steal ukraine
from russia but he's been humiliated
there
that russia is a victim he has a long
narrative of victimhood that nato is
encroaching
and that the west wants to take russia
apart and this is a man who's very
isolated he doesn't talk to many people
he has people around him who don't
challenge him and i think that's the
danger and that's why it's very hard to
predict his actions on the basis of any
rationality
just tell us some more about that than
sir roderick about this sort of sense of
victimhood that you think president
putin will be facing i mean you
obviously were in russia just i mean how
is he viewed by his inner circle is he
viewed as the person who will make the
best decisions does that no sense of
questioning if his decisions are right
well i remember when i remember sitting
with tony blair when he tried to discuss
church near with putin and whenever you
raise the subject objection with putin
he would go off into a 20-minute
emotional rant and there was no way of
turning this into a discussion and when
i talked to putin's staff he said
exactly the same problem arose when they
tried to discuss uh chechnya with putin
other parts of the conversation he'd be
perfectly rational and really quite
sensible um but when the emotion gets
held i mean when he feels that russia is
being victimized and he is i think
convinced himself of that
then you get this sense of vengeance
and he is so often acted in a way that
is very damaging to russia's interests
so when we look at whether storm
vladimir is about to hit ukraine we have
to factor in uh the element that putin
may not be doing his mass in the same
way that we do the math
yeah and so rodrick then if dealing with
an irrational actor then uh do you then
support this idea i know that's been
sort of um dismissed now of putting some
kind of force within ukraine to
completely deter him from ever stepping
foot into that territory even a rational
actor sees that there's a huge army
there he's probably unlikely to invade
his name
no i think that would be a crazy thing
to do ukraine is not a member of nato
it's not subject to article 5 of the
nato charter
and
if we put
if nato put forces into ukraine to fight
russia you're getting on the first step
to a really really serious war um and
i don't think that's the way to handle
it i think that nato has done completely
the right thing by reinforcing its
position on the eastern flanks in a
purely defensive way
but uh let us not give russia a further
excuse to think that nato is trying to
attack russia we know it isn't but there
is a perception
in the heads of some people in the
kremlin but nato
has got some plot to encroach on russia
um
it would be a certain lose-lose if we
did that
okay sergey line do appreciate your
expertise analysis thank you for being
with us this morning
thank you
hello and welcome back now the cost of
living crisis is affecting people up and
down the country as household bills soar
fuel prices are also at record levels
with petrol hitting a new high earlier
this week now one of those people
affected by the rise in the cost of
living is richard luke he relies heavily
on his car as a wheelchair user living
with cerebral palsy richard joins us now
live good morning to you richard thank
you for being with us just describe
how valuable and useful your car is to
on a day-to-day basis
well our car is essential to
get me to appointments to get me to
uh the the train station so i can travel
on the the trains
and it's essential for getting our
daughter to school
uh the public transport links are not
very
good around here where where i live so
it's a necessity for us to have a car
and how was the rise in petrol prices
then hit your budget richard
well we now have to think about
um
any journeys that we have or whether the
priority is filling up the car
or
having additional um
shopping or things of that nature
i mean you mentioned that you you can't
do without it to get around so you have
to make that tough decision about
putting fuel in the car or
or paying the other household bills now
the government say they understand uh
what's going on with people around the
country do you think they do
i think i think it's uh
very difficult for them to understand
i think that the
200 pounds that they they say that
they're going to give people is just
storing up problems further down the
line because people will have to pay
that back
um it's just really a
you know a plaster over a big crack
really
i mean what other help would you like to
see uh richard not just for people in
your situation but more broadly for
everyone who's struggling to pay their
bills and and keep the heating on and
feed their families i think there should
be there should have been a windfall tax
on some of the energy companies they've
made record profits um with the fuel
companies as well that they're not quick
enough to reduce the cost of fuel
i know that oil is a at an all-time high
at the moment but i think that energy
companies should work with their
customers and support them particularly
customers that have
um
equipment uh that they need to
use to live that needs to be on constant
charge and things like that
yeah i mean as you know richard those
energy companies say they pay plenty of
tax but you mentioned their record
profits just a couple of weeks ago i
mean
describe for us how that made you feel
when you you know couldn't put petrol in
your car but you saw bp and shell
recording record billion pound profits
well it
makes you realize that that you know
that they're not in it
with everyone else it's all about profit
and it does it really really
um makes me quite angry uh
frustrated
and i think there's a lot more that they
could do i do realize that they do pay a
large amount of tax but they make huge
profits and we never see those profits
passed on at the point
okay uh richard lucca thank you so much
for joining us this morning that's
richard luke there who's been struggling
to fill his uh car with petrol because
of their rise in the cost listing
richard i do appreciate your time with
us this morning on skyny's breakfast
thanks for being with us
well still to come this morning plenty
more as storm eunice hits the united
kingdom strong winds have been recorded
up to 90 mile an hour gusts as the winds
hit the coast we'll be live across the
country bringing you the very latest as
the storm makes its way inland a rare
red weather warning has been issued this
is a risk to life and limb will have all
the coverage as storm units makes
landfall in the uk throughout the
morning stay with us here on sky news
[Music]
you